كيف
يتعامل مجتمع الاستخبارات مع شيء كهذا،
هل يحاولون معرفة ما إذا كانت هذه
روبوتات إذا كانت هذه حكومة أجنبية
إذا كان هذا حقيقيًا، أعني كيف نظروا
إلى شعبية مقاطع الفيديو هذه، كل ما
سبق لأنهم  "نحاول
معرفة أن هذا الأمر قد قطع مسافة بعيدة جدًا
وبسرعة كبيرة، كما تعلم منذ 48 ساعة مضت، حدث هذا
مع إحدى الشخصيات المؤثرة على Tik Tok، حيث قامت بنشر
تسجيل لرد فعل شخص ما على
الرسالة وهذا هو أول ما
نراه من الرسالة ولكنك تريد ذلك  نوع من
العودة إلى أين يقع مسرح الجريمة الرقمية،
أين بدأ هذا، ثم كيف
تحركت بهذه الطريقة، لديها
175000 متابع، وتحصل على 800000 مشاهدة،
وتحصل على 80000 إعجاب، وهو ما يحدث عندما
تتحدث عن رسالة من بن لادن
تبرر 911  إن الدعوة إلى
تدمير إسرائيل والإطاحة العنيفة
بالولايات المتحدة
وتكرار كل مجاز معاد للسامية في
المجموعة الأساسية أمر غير معتاد أن نرى ذلك
ولكن بعد ذلك ينتشر وفقًا لصحيفة
نيويورك تايمز أه الليلة 14.2 مليون
مشاهدة ومشاركات لذا أم  إنهم يحاولون
معرفة ما إذا كان هناك شيء آخر
وراء ذلك يقود كرة الثلج هذه إلى أسفل التل
عندما أصبحت أكبر هل هي روبوت أم أنها
ميزة ذكاء اصطناعي تعلم أنها تسببت في
تحركها بسرعة هل يمكننا التحدث فقط عن
الشخص الذي كتب  هذه الرسالة أعني
فكرة أن الناس يتعاطفون
معه، أعني أنك كنت آخر
صحفي غربي أجرى مقابلة مع
أسامة بن لادن، لأنه إذا كان أي من مستخدمي تيك توك الشباب
يشاهدون من شاهد هذا
الفيديو، أعني ماذا ستقول كيف
ستقول  تحدث عن تلك المقابلة، كيف
تصفها؟ هل تعلم أن هناك
أشياء في تلك الرسالة ذات صلة بالأشياء التي
قالها لي في تلك الليلة كما
تعلم في قاعدة لتنظيم القاعدة في عام 1998
والتي قال إنك تعلم أنني أتوقع
يومًا أسود لها؟  أمريكا بعدها
لن تتحد الدول كان
يشجع على ثورة أه قال
انتصرنا على قوة عظمى قبل
سقوط الروس والاتحاد السوفييتي عندما خرجنا
لهم من أفغانستان لكنه قال أيضا
وهذا موضوع رسالته كما
تعلمون  سوف تفهمون هذا كشعب فقط
عندما تجدون حكومة
تمثل مصلحتكم بدلاً من مصلحة
اليهود، لقد بدأ الموضوع المعادي للسامية
من أسامة بن لادن، كما تعلمون، قبل
وقت طويل من اكتشاف العالم
لهذه الرسالة ولكن تردد صداها
هناك
نعم